SPEAKER: We've looked
at creating dashboards
to visualize the
health of our systems
and at automating them
using the API in Terraform.
But today I'm here to show you
how to use the new dashboard
editor to visualize your
cloud-monitoring data
like never before.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we start, let's
quickly review what
makes for a good dashboard.
Generally, you want to focus on
the key signals that represent
the health of your service.
These are covered in the
"Monitoring Distributed
Systems" chapter
of the SRE book.
And we call them
the golden signals.
You can automate creating
a dashboard using the API
or Terraform.
But today I want to show you
how to use the new dashboard
editor in the Cloud Console.
Right away, you can
see that the new editor
looks very different.
There's now a list of widgets
on the right to pick from
and a grid for laying out your
dashboard in the main panel.
I specifically want to show you
three things-- the new widgets,
the new layout options, and
the new chart configuration
options.
Let's dig in.
Start by adding a
widget to the dashboard.
The Gauge widget
finally gives you
a way to show a single
number on a dashboard
as an indicator of health.
For example, you
can use it to show
mean CPU limit use of all
containers in the workspace.
One thing I really love
about this new widget
is the ability to specify the
expected range for the metric.
For example, you can set
a warning threshold that
will turn the chart yellow,
or a danger threshold
that will turn it red.
This gauge is a good way
to represent the saturation
signal.
If the containers, on average,
are not close to the limit,
there should be plenty
of capacity left.
If you care about
a specific service,
you could filter for just
the resources you need.
A gauge is a great way to see
the current value of a metric,
but it doesn't show you
any historical data.
If you need that, you can
use the new Scorecard widget.
This is a great way to
visualize a signal like latency.
You can also use the warning
and danger thresholds
to change the color
of the chart when
the value exceeds a threshold.
This is great to let
you know at a glance
that something is wrong.
If you just want to see the
current state of a metric
and what range
it's in, the widget
can be toggled to not
show you the times series
chart behind it.
This way you can see just
the current state of a metric
and whether or not it's
within a good range.
The last new widget I
want to show you is Text.
Yes, Text.
You might be thinking,
sure, you can now
add text boxes to dashboards.
That's fine.
But here's the cool
thing about this.
The Text widget
supports Markdown,
which lets you
format the text, add
links, and generally,
make it look
like exactly what you want.
This is a great way to add
in-context documentation
to your dashboard.
These new widgets are great,
but what can you do with them?
Let's have a look at the new
way to lay out your dashboard.
There are now two
options for layout--
Grid, the rows and columns
you're used to, and Mosaic.
The Mosaic option lets you
size each chart individually
and place them where you
want on the dashboard.
You can use this to create
a dashboard like this,
showing us service traffic
as measured by requests
across the top, with a
column of health indicators
on the left, and
documentation on the right.
This is a great way to
present information.
The last thing I
want to show you
is the new way to configure
the charts on the dashboard.
When creating a
chart, you now have
the option of switching
between the Basic mode, which
should be enough for most
users most of the time,
and Advanced mode.
For example, we can switch
to the Advanced mode
for a Heatmap chart to
specify exactly how we
want the data to be preprocessed
and which aligner to use,
if we need that.
This gives you total control
over how the charts interpret
and present data.
Thanks for joining me today.
We took a look at the
new dashboard editor
and saw how to use it to create
a dashboard using the Gauge,
Scorecard, and Text widgets.
We also checked out the new
layout options and Advanced
chart configuration mode.
Now you're ready to use it
to create your dashboards
and keep an eye on the
health of your services.
Thanks for watching, and
come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]